what's been your worst property deal I
think it's one of the flips definitely
both flips we done to earn more cash to
then buy more hmos and both of them
turned into disasters tell me about it
we ripped it all out gave it to the
Builder and said right see in couple
weeks went back after a few weeks
everything was ripped out looked good
started putting it back together you get
the usual this doesn't feel quite right
so we were up every week started having
the proper look and then basically
things were getting done quite quickly
because he was cutting corn us and he've
gone from building site to almost
finished in about 2 weeks so the alarm
Bells were on on the last visit that we
made before we a company so we went up
there we went in went straight to the on
Suite running water went to the back of
the toilet pulled the fit in it there's
no pipes in the floor so he's got
everything running but he's got no
drainage so the minute we'd sold it it
had the flooded would have had major
problems so ended up sending about
10,000 ripping back his work and doing
good the profit was doing the job so
still made profit yeah still 25 Grand on
that deal yeah